now at least 60 people have been killed
in an attack in Northern Burkina Faso
authorities say about a hundred men
wearing what looked like military
uniforms raided the village of karma in
yatenga Province no group has claimed
responsibility Nicholas hack is
following developments from Senegal's
capital Dakar Nicholas this was a
horrific attack by all accounts but the
details still coming into Focus as we
speak tell us what you know
certainly another vicious attack in this
aisle yesterday just a days ago there
was it was on the Malian side of the
Border where civilians were killed just
as people were celebrating the Muslim
festivities of Eid now on the Burkina
Burkina Faso side of the border that the
two countries shared an attack a
gruesome attack it started according to
eyewitness on Thursday at 7 30 in the
morning when the village of karma in the
yatenga province next to uriguya was
encircled by men in uniform so initially
the villagers thought that the men in
uniform were there to support them so
they were cheering the fact that these
men in uniform had surrounded them but
from 7 30 to 1500 local time in the
space of eight hours eyewitness say
there was sheer violence with these men
shooting down men women and children
at least half of the village have has
been killed the village of 400 people
according to eyewitness now according to
the prosecutor only 60 people were
killed but there has been no statement
from the military Junta in place in
wagadugu we're waiting for them to
communicate about what has just happened
the latest uh attack but it comes on the
heels of another attack that happened in
that region that was targeting the
military there so some people believe
that this may have been a Revenge attack
still a lack of clarity but what's clear
is that the violence keeps increasing in
that region you know there was a
military coup in Burkina last year
partly based on the premise that the
country was losing the fight against
armed groups is this hunter that is
taking power in Burkina Faso doing any
better
well certainly in the words of the
military Junta leader Ibrahim the young
Captain just weeks ago he said that the
government forces had lost about 40
percent of the country now Burkina Faso
is roughly the size of the United
Kingdom imagine if Scotland and Wales
were out of the control of London well
that's what's happening in Burkina Faso
there's sheer desperation from
government forces try to fight off armed
groups and since the French have left
when the the the military to severe
military cooperation with the French and
that the Americans cannot help the
military agenda because effectively it
is not a democratically elected
government that's in place well there's
a security Gap in place so the uh the
Junta are looking at its people it's at
its young people and calling for a mass
mobilization so anyone above the age of
18 men or women will have to go on the
front line but given the fact that they
are losing they're going from defeat to
defeat there is mounting criticism
inside Burkina Faso uh towards the
military regunta just uh just over the
weekend a new Civil Society group a
coalition group called The United group
from Burkina Faso said that it was
alarmed by the deterioration
deteriorating security situation
two million people are displaced in this
country there is in every family a
family member that has either been
displaced or killed by this uptick of
violence
Nicholas hack reporting from Dakar thank
you very much